it was really important to me to do well
on my GMAT after completing an
undergraduate degree in business I
wanted to complete a finance master at
the London School of Economics and then
after some years working at McKinsey I
wanted to do an MBA at insert and for
both of these programs
I need a GMAT and I needed a good GMAT a
good score I really needed to get this
right and with only three weeks of
preparation I scored above 700 on my
first and only sitting of the GMAT exam
hi there my name is Heinrich and welcome
to my channel firm learning if you're a
first time view of this channel on this
channel I try to help you to become
successful in the first years of your
career I draw for my experience having
worked at McKinsey for six years in a
consulting role and now in a sea level
position at a German retailer and on
this channel I try to pass on my
knowledge and my experiences with the
hope that this is helpful and valuable
to you if you're taking any value out of
this video at all please hit the like
button for the YouTube algorithm and
also please subscribe to my channel to
stay up to date on all my content and
also hit the notification Bay to make
sure that you really see every video
that I bring out for those of you I
haven't seen it yet
I recently also started an Instagram
channel where I post daily content daily
updates for you with little tips and
tricks what you can do to become
successful in the first years of your
career in today's video we are going to
talk about all things GMAT as escort
above 700 or my first sitting of the
exam I want to pass on four things for
you in this video first I want to give
you a bit of context I'm going to
explain to you why the GMAT is so
important and why you need to do it well
in order to get access to the top
graduate business programs that you want
to study it second I'm gonna share some
preparation advice what I did how I
studied for the GMAT that enabled me
with only three weeks of preparation to
score above 700 and my first sitting of
the exam third I'm going to talk about
the economists remit Utah online program
that I use to help me prepare for my
dream it and that I found insanely
valuable and then fourth I'm going to
talk about all the books that I bought
these are probably the most widely used
the most prevalent books on the GMAT
preparation market and I'm going to give
you my briefing
candid assessment which of these books I
found helpful invaluable in which of
these books I just found a waste of time
and money
let's start by briefly going over my
personal GMAT learning story after I
completed my undergraduate degree in
business from the University of Munich I
wanted to complete a finance master at
the London School of Economics and I
knew I needed a GMAT for that so I did
lots of research on the exam I purchased
the couple of books and then really
studied hard for three weeks we worked
up well for me I scored above 700 I was
able to get into the finance master
program that I wanted at the LSE and
after my master program I started as
consultant for McKinsey and the Berlin
office and then after a couple of years
with McKinsey I had the opportunity that
McKinsey offer to sponsor my MBA at
first I wanted to redo the GMAT for the
MBA because I only studied for three
weeks and I saw that many people study
for much longer amounts of time and I
felt if I would just put in the time I
would be able to score even a higher
recite so I started learning actually
purchasing a couple of other books which
is the main reason why this tech is now
so high but then after couple of weeks
back into the preparation I decided for
myself that I actually did not want to
take the exam again the main reason was
it at the moment I was working full time
for McKinsey I didn't have that much
time and I also talked to many alumni of
the NC MBA program that I wanted to get
into and most often told me that the
g-men reside that I have is already
completely fine because I scored above
700 as the Gmail was also valid for five
years and then decided to not do it
again - just take the result that I have
and in the end was the right decision
because I got it
so now that that's out of the way let's
jump in let's jump into the first point
what is the GMAT why it is so important
GMAT stands for Graduate Management
Admission Test and it is an entry exam
required by pretty much all prestigious
graduate level business programs so both
the pre experienced master programs but
also the post experience MBA programs to
get admitted to them so this means that
if you want to get into one of the
globally leading business programs on a
graduate level you really need to take
the GMAT exam and you will need a good
score in order to get admitted to the
absolute top programs so what is the
exam nowadays the consists of four parts
first the logical writing assessment
second integrated reasoning third the
quant part and four
the verbal part so let's briefly go over
these components let's start with the
first one the elliptical writing
assessment in this section you're
required to write a short essay to a
specific question that you are giving
then in the exam the main reason why
this exists in the exam is that the
business schools want to make sure that
you actually wrote your essays your
application essays you're safe if your
application essays on flawless English
but you score really bad on this
analytical essay exercise the most
likely this means that you actually did
not write your essays yourself but you
probably had a ghostwriter what this
means for you is that this section of
the exam is pretty much only a hygiene
factor it is not too difficult to score
in the higher segments of this section
of the test if your answers just above
average this should usually be fine for
most schools here you want to make sure
that you are not raising any red flags
by having a score which is really low
especially if this is not matched at all
by the quality of your other application
assets integrated reasoning is the
second section of the test here they
have different types of exercises where
they show you charts data diagrams and
they just want to see how when you're
able to draw conclusions from these
things that are presented to you the
section was introduced to the exam in
2012 it did not exist before that and it
is not part of the final GMAT score and
for these reasons it is not that
important this way just make sure that
you score above average here you do not
want to raise any red flags by having an
especially bad score but usually if you
score well in the quantum the verbal
part there should be no reason why you
shouldn't be able to also score here
high as well so make sure that you
familiarize yourself with the types of
question that you're able to score on a
solid level but this is not what we make
or break your application in the end
especially if you have at least an
average above average score now what are
the two really important and interesting
parts and this is the one part and the
verbal part as you can see also timewise
these two parts make the majority of the
test and from the scores of these two
sections your final GMAT score will be
built the combined score that can come
out of the verbal in one section will
range between 200 and 800 so this is a
range of scores that you can get and
this is the main score that you will use
for your business school applications
this is really the key section where you
want to score where this is the section
that you want to prepare for this is the
score that matters this is what business
could look
for sowhat's course they actually need
to in order to get admitted to a top
Business School graduate level program
let's look into the statistics of some
MBA programs because most people redo
the GMAT for an MBA as per the current
Financial Times global MBA ranking the
program that is at the moment ranked
number one is the Harvard Business
School MBA program if you look into the
efficient latest class profile of the
Harvard MBA the median GMAT score is 730
so 738 hundred and the total range
deviates between five hundred ninety and
eight hundred this is pretty impressive
because they're only a couple of people
worldwide to actually achieve a perfect
eight hundred score on the GMAT exam but
this also shows you that you can study
at Harvard Business School with the GMAT
of only 590 which is indeed quite a low
score for such a leading MBA program
however what you also need to recognize
is that if you look outside of the u.s.
programs more local programs tend to
have GMAT averages which are
significantly lower just as an example
let's look into the best German MBA
program it's on ranked 64 on the current
Financial Times ranking it is the w hu
ba program they do not disclose the
exact average in the class so they talk
about that from their perspective most
MBA schools require GMAT score buff 600
to get admitted and just from the rid of
desk research reading online forums and
so on I concluded that the average of
the w hu is probably around 650 so why
this is not an official number you can
see that it is significantly below the
top MBA programs and it is much easier
to get a score of 650 then to get a
score above 700 so how difficult is it
really to score higher on the GMAT what
I have prepared for you here is a
percentile table where you can see in
what percentile you fall depending on
the total score that you achieve the
percentiles changeable your year but the
mean score is 545 on the GMAT if you
want to belong to the top 20% of the
GMAT test takers you a need a score of
at least 660 the score that most people
try to go for and the score that most
people try to consider really
competitive for the best programs a 700
and what you can see here is the 700
roughly corresponds to the top 10% of
GMAT test takers and if you want to be
part of the top 1%
GMAT test takers you need to score 760
or above of course you need to be aware
that those people who take the GMAT
usually have completed at least one
undergraduate university degree they're
applying for master an MBA degree which
shows they have some level of ambition
so it might be more difficult than in
other groups to score within the top 10
percent of test takers let's start with
some overall GMAT test prep advice what
did I do to score where with 3 weeks of
preparation the first thing that really
worked well for me is that I make sure
at the time I prepare for the GMAT is
really blocked by that I didn't want to
be distracted by any other activities I
didn't want to go to the university or
go to a job and then only in the evening
be able to work on my GMAT I blocked
three weeks and really dedicated myself
to GMAT preparation full-time this way I
put my full attention on the GMAT
preparation every single day of the
three weeks and this meant that I
learned usually more than 6 hours each
of these days of course I've could have
gone even longer about at some point
your brain just isn't able to process
the material anymore at least mine isn't
I had several friends at the time who
didn't want to do that they continued to
go to university or to their job and
then only learn for the GMAT maybe at
the evening or at the weekends if you do
this and are still able to score well
you have my highest respect but or just
I have observed from myself is just so
much more difficult if after a long
worked already many hours then in the
evening you want to concentrate yourself
again and try to learn try to get into
the material this is just so challenging
if you're somehow able really block
yourself the time for a couple of weeks
and then you will be much better off my
second insight is that when you learn
for the GMAT the Pareto principle or the
8020 rule really holds true after a
couple of weeks of preparation you very
quickly you reach a certain plateau and
if you reach that and if then you want
to further improve the time that you
need to improve further we just go up
exponentially and at some point you just
need to ask yourself whether the time
investors worth it or not for me
probably that point came after two weeks
after two weeks I started to realize if
I progress really slowed down
significantly and my strategy walls had
already had the GMAT test day after week
three of my preparation if I would not
have achieved the test besides that I
wanted I would pro
we have who schedule to another test
date in the future because as you might
know you're able to directly cancel your
GMAT test results in a few minutes after
you complete the test the next key piece
of preparation advice is that you should
really do mock tests and the one that I
like best that I felt like resembled
most the actual test in the end was the
Manhattan mock test you can either buy
exit to it on their website or actually
if you get some of their books and I
recommend you later some of them the
test access is already included with
them there are others as well I just fed
to the Manhattan prep exam really
closely resented it's the real thing in
the end so how exactly did I do it so
after two or three days of studying so
after got the basic concept of what the
daemon was all about I decided to take
the very first mock exam to set a
baseline for myself so to understand
from where I'm starting and I remember
that after these two or three days is
caught slightly above 600 so was a 610
or 620 or something like that and from
then on one time four weig and sometimes
even two times per week I took a new
version of the mock exam to track my
progress and understand where I'm
standing this helped me to get a live
feedback whether I'm on the right path
with other learning the studying that
I'm doing is really helping me to
advance my score and in fact the last
mock exam that took roughly half a week
before I took the actual exam I score to
710 which was absolutely in the range of
the final result then I got in the real
test the next preparation advice is that
while I was studying I studied on some
actual real GMAT test prep paper so I'm
not sure if you know but on the actual
GMAT exam the type of paper you can use
to make notes it's standardized and it's
not a normal piece of paper instead it's
foiled paper and you can buy paper that
very closely resembles this foil paper
here I got a set that I bought myself
that I use and as you can see it has a
special glossy foil surface so of course
it's not hugely different than writing
on normal paper but at least you should
be aware of that and I just wanted that
my preparation comes as close as
possible to the actual test experience
so I bought this prep set I will leave
your link below down in the description
and as you can see there's still some
notes from the time when I really learn
for the GMAT myself so it made me a bit
sentimental when I actually looked at
this but whenever I did mock exercises
whenever I studied I made up
kind of always trying to take notes and
to ride on this actual GMAT paper and of
course it's not only a paper but it's
also the pen you need a special foil
marker in order to write on this paper
you were given that at the test center
but I found it helpful to have already
written with it to a favor any work with
it in advance it was no surprise to me
at all and my last little prep advice is
that even though it's hard work and it's
very serious for all of us to get this
test right still try to see the fun of
it and the use of it beyond the exam
itself so I found that for me just
preparing and studying for the GMAT exam
that really helped improve my
quantitative skills so you will take
something out of it that we go beyond
the exam date itself there's a use
beyond the actual GMAT test the next
thing I want to talk about is the
Economist jima tutor this is a program
that I found insanely helpful and
valuable when studying for my GMAT exam
at the core of it you have an online
program that teaches you all the
strategies all the tips you need to
improve for the GMAT and it also
includes lots and lots of more exercises
besides that also included are some
private one-on-one video chat tutor
sessions with some experience GMAT
instructors you can submit essays that
they will rate one of the best things I
thought is that they have a score
improvement guarantee of 50 to 70 points
depending on which program to take and
50 points are just huge 50 points are an
absolute make-or-break of your GMAT exam
so if you already took the exam and want
to improve your score they guarantee you
that with your program you can improve
by this amount of points and if you
don't you get your money back and if
you're a first time exam taker they will
do a base exam at the beginning to get
your baseline and then we guarantee to
you that they will improve your least by
that number of points and if you don't
you get your money back and I have to
admit it's quite pricey it's quite an
expensive program but this way I really
rationalize that for me that if I do not
get the result that I want I will just
get my money back and hey for me it
worked really well so if you want to
check this out as well I have a link to
this course below in the video
description and the best thing is that
if you sign up via the link you can get
a 7-day free trial and in these seven
days you can check out all the functions
by yourself for free so you can really
get a good feel whether this is
something that works for you and that
adds value for you so let's do some
brief and candid reviews of the books
and other materials I use to prepare for
my GMAT exam I really hope that this
helps you get and understand
that might be worth your time and your
investment let's start with the official
GMAC books so these are the official do
you make books there's an overall guide
and then there are two more books one
for the quantitative section and then
one for the verbal section so these are
as I told you the two main most
important sections of the test these
books have lots of practice exams and
this is why I believe they're great so
if you really want to get a whole bunch
of exams that you want to go through and
work with and this really helps and the
other process of course these are the
official books and the main reason for
me why I bought them is that I just
didn't want to miss out on any of the
official information that the GMAT test
takers themselves have put out there so
I'd say that these books were a helpful
and great if you want to do lots of
practices but they were a bit lacking on
the really difficult upper-level types
of questions so my opinion is that I
would recommend you to get them these
are the official books after all and if
you sign up for the GMAT usually there's
also an option to then get these books a
bit cheaper so it should be quite a good
tilazway there lots of great practice
exams in it just be sure that you also
get some additional material because
otherwise you might struggle with the
more difficult GMAT questions let's now
look into some of the books of Kaplan
Kaplan is a pretty well known and famous
GMAT test prep provider as well at the
time about two books from Kaplan one was
the Kaplan GMAT premier book I believe
right now they discontinued the book and
we package it into some of the other
material and frankly I did not really
like this book and the main reason was
that I felt that the material in here is
far too easy the book claims that this
book has quote everything you need to
score higher and it also claims higher
score guaranteed and I can just tell you
that this book was extremely basic the
strategies and exercises cover did not
even come close to help you really ace
the higher more difficult questions in
the exam so even though this focus is
continued at the moment for this
experience I would be a bit careful with
the Kapler material especially their
more basic ones at least this book
really surprised me in a negative way so
really make sure you know what you're
buying if you're getting into the Kevlar
material however there's also positive
thing I want to mention about Kaplan and
this is this book the GMAT 800 book and
this is a book that still exists today
and this is now the capital book that
really focuses on the more differ
advanced students and their claim as
advanced prep for advanced students
maths are the questions that most people
get wrong and yes I really liked this
one this one does cover some great and
advanced strategies and this one really
helped me to get to the higher levels to
solve the more difficult problems in the
GMAT the books that I can recommend you
most to prepare for your GMAT based on
the material that I use this the
Manhattan GMAT strategy guide series
it's a series of ten or so books and
these books are really great because
they both teach you some great and also
advanced to energies on how you should
take her the different types of
questions that you're facing with the
GMAT and they also have lots of practice
exams so they're books on all kinds of
topics their books on fractions
decimates a presence on a gap around
word problems geography number
properties sentence correction
integrated reasoning on the essay part
and so on so this is really all the
stuff that you need in order to get your
GMAT right and the great additional
bonus is that if you buy the set as it
also says here it includes six free
online exams from Manhattan so this is
the mock exam that I recommended to you
earlier I said that from all the mock
exams that I looked into the Manhattan
mock exam was the one that most closely
resembled the real thing in the end and
also the results that I got in the ideas
of score were really closely matching
the actual reside that I got in my rear
GMAT test and if you look into the
description down below you can find a
link to this book serious and also the
other books that I recommended in my
description so have a look check it out
of this might be interesting to you
finally I want to discuss another
Manhattan book and this was the
Manhattan advanced one preparation book
and from the series there some other
books as well and in this series there
are some other books from Manhattan as
we're really deep diving on individual
elements of the GMAT test I found that
yes this was helpful and if there are
some areas where you really struggle
with and if you have enough time that
you've went through all the other
materials and yes this might be head for
the person you have found that this was
probably just too much I didn't really
need that if you have all the other
stuff that's already enough but if there
are some areas we really struggle and
want some additional insight some
additional tips and tricks then yes
these advanced books on the specific
topics might be helpful interesting this
way I hope this video helped you
understand how I scored above 700 in my
GMAT exam with only three weeks of
preparation and I hope that this helped
inspire to motivated you to also get
your GMAT
prep right and also help you achieve a
higher result I would have cost laughs
to hear about your GMAT test prep
experience you agree with the tips that
I have did you do something else what
are your top tips to ace the GMAT let me
know in the comments below and answer
every single comment that you write so
I'd love to have a discussion with you
here on this channel and if you took any
value out of this video at all please
smash the like button for the YouTube
algorithm and also subscribe to this
channel to stay up to date on all the
content that I'm releasing I will bring
out at least one video every single
Saturday for you if you want to get even
more content from me follow my Instagram
and the firm learning on my Instagram
I'm releasing daily pieces of content
for you on how to be successful in the
first years of your career thank you for
watching this was Jaime from firm
learning stay safe and to the next time